[Music]
our centers for Tartu through time
the majority of the post-earthquake
restoration work now complete in the chi
boy and regular town centers we now turn
our mind to the long-term future of all
our centers retailing trends are
evolving online shopping is prevalent
and big-box stores are increasingly
popular it's vital our town centers our
lifestyle centers with complementary
activities in community recreational and
entertainment facilities all creating a
place where people like to spend time
our district our future why Mac you era
2048 aims to provide further
opportunities for increased business
development focused on the existing town
centres of Ren your own people confirm
the location of the main town center or
woody and Pegasus and will put in while
also supporting the existing would end
and Pegasus town center areas proposed
longer-term expansion directions for Ren
Europe's am center including big-box
retail and integrate the future
mixed-use business areas into Clyde for
town center and continue to monitor
delivery of the Oxford town center
strategy so what do you think let us
know your thoughts and find out more
about the district development strategy
at Waimakariri govt tea in via